all right peter let's get to the pro
bowl and ordinarily i would say i don't
want to talk about the pro bowl but
here's what i'd like to talk about and i
recall
2012 the time magazine profile of roger
goodell remember the one with the
enforcer he's holding the football on
the cover in that article there was a
reference to an idea that had been
presented to him by then buccaneers head
coach greg schiano who while at rutgers
had been the coach when eric legrand
suffered a serious permanent paralysis
on a kick return shiano's idea to
replace the kickoff give the team that
would be kicking the ball off
possession of the ball fourth and 15.
you can punt you can go for it you can
fake punt you can do whatever you want
it's fourth and fifteen you decide how
to proceed and here we are over seven
years after that article came out that
concept has made its way to the pro bowl
now it's only if you are essentially
trying to simulate an on-site kick there
will be no kickoffs there will be no
punts out of fourth and 15.
you do that only if you want to try to
keep possession of the ball and peter
this is the key factor if the nfl is
ever going to get rid of the kickoff
this is the key factor you need to have
the team that is losing
you have an opportunity to try to keep
possession of the ball and this fourth
and 15 play could be the answer if they
finally decide at some point to just get
rid of the kickoff completely
i think shiano originally did this
out of basically goodwill and very very
good intentions
and mike i think it's a good idea to try
because i i do think that the kind of
head-on collisions
that are created uh in the kicking game
and look mike
one of the things that has happened you
know for all these special teams coaches
who
you know i have great respect for mike
westoff and all of these guys who over
the years have said you've got to keep
the kickoff in the game
and i i don't want to be a heretic here
but my biggest question is why
how many great plays
this year
on a kickoff were there
and how many violent collisions there
were more violent collisions on kickoff
return and coverage this year then there
were great plays and at some point you
have to ask yourself is it really worth
it to have the kick off in the game
and again i don't want to be a heretic i
don't want to ruin the game
um you know you you want to keep the
foot in football i get it
but to me
this is
the
natural progression
of everybody trying to basically say
let's make the game a little bit safer
and let's make the game a little bit
less violent
and so that's i i would definitely be in
favor of that i think it's going to be a
cool experiment we'll see where it goes
well i mean on one hand how many kick
returns do we really see anymore more
often than not especially now that the
ball is dead the moment it hits in the
end zone you just see the football hit
the ground and the guy going like this
right and it goes over his head and hits
the ground and you put the ball on the
25 anyway and the onside kick has become
almost impossible to recover so look i i
don't know what the percentages are for
converting fourth and 15 when people
know that that it's coming it's not a
fake punt but a play from scrimmage
it's got to be higher than what the
onside kick currently is because the
onside kick conversion percentage is
minuscule at this point it's so
minuscule that when the the falcons were
able to rattle off two or three of them
in a row against the saints it was one
of the stories of the year because it
just doesn't happen
and you know mike i also think this that
if you're talking about
you know john i talked to john lynch for
my podcast this week and he was talking
about how raheem mostert was such a good
special teams player
that it was like in the old days
remember when when marv levy jim kelly
was begging for steve tasker to be used
as a wide receiver and marv levy would
say i'm using them 25 28 snaps a game on
special teams i can't give them to you
you know to wear them out in the passing
game we got a good enough offense we
need to have great special teams and in
a lot of ways raheem mostert was such a
good special teams player and the 49ers
were okay at running back that they were
saying we're using we're maxing him out
on special teams and and i think the
devaluation
of the kickoff and because so many punts
are either fair caught or kicked out of
bounds
right now that in my opinion the
emphasis on special teams really has
declined so the 49ers say let's play him
in the backfield especially when we have
injuries
yeah and for so many guys performance on
special teams becomes that way that they
prove their worth and they end up
getting the attention of the offensive
or defensive coaches and then the next
thing you know they're contributors
they're just gonna have to find another
path and you know i feel badly for the
guys who make their career playing
special teams of matthew slater for
example
but
the game is changing and the game has
evolved in order to survive and they've
taken away these high impact collisions
when you have people from the league who
are saying that kickoff is the most
dangerous play in the game well you're
you're virtually guaranteeing they're
going to get rid of it at some point
it's a no-brainer it's going to be gone
but you have to have a way for a team
that is trailing to get back into the
game peter six years ago in the run-up
to the super bowl that was played in new
york roger goodell was asked by cnbc who
he roots for and he said i root for the
team that is losing they want the team
that is losing a game to have a chance
to get back into it so this fourth and
fifteen play is the way that you can
give that team a chance if you do get
rid of the kickoff
and one other thing to keep in mind mike
about this this is not the ruination of
football it's not the this it's not
making football a circus it is simply
trying to make football a safer game
what's more likely next right here
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports